every single minute computers across the
world collect millions of gigabytes of
data
what can you do to make sense of this
mountain of data how do data scientists
process this wealth of information
and use it in the applications that
power our model work data is a fuel for
the digital age it powers machine
learning and artificial intelligence
data scientists use this fuel to conduct
research
find results and communicate their
findings you will leverage the power of
python and apply to real life data
science problems you will explore
applications in various domains hone
your intuition for the theory underlying
these methods and consider different
ways of verifying your models to
identify
and reduce potential biases job
prospects for data scientists are
growing and the knowledge and skills
gained from these courses will open up
your work to machine learning and
artificial intelligence learn data
science and process the fuel that powers
our modern world
[Music]